yeah we're starting to get surrounded
they're taking the North Front
scaffolding
yeah let's forget
[Applause]
the door has been breached if we're
gaining access into the capitol
um
Senator Schumer is at a secure location
and they're locked down in the Senate
there has to be some way we can maintain
the sense that people have
that there's some security or some
confidence
that government can function and that we
can elect the president of the United
States
did we go back into session
we did go back into session but now
apparently everybody on the floor
putting on a tear gas masks to prepare
for a bridge
well I'm trying to get more information
they're putting on their tear gas masks
thousand members they're all walking
over now through the tunnels
I'm gonna call up the effing Secretary
of DOD we have some Senators who are
still in their hideaways they need
massive Personnel now can you get the
Maryland National Guard to come to I
have something to say Mr secretary well
I'm going to call the mayor of
Washington D.C right now and see what uh
other Outreach she has to other police
departments our leader employer has
mentioned
foreign
I don't know if you have been approached
about the Virginia National Guard Mr
Hoyer was connected I was speaking to uh
Governor Hogan uh but I still think you
probably need the okay of the uh
the federal government in order to come
into another jurisdiction
they said somebody was shot it's just
it's just horrendous and all at the
instigation of the president of the
United States
okay thank you Governor I appreciate
what you're doing and if you don't mind
I'd like to stay in touch thank you
thank you so much
it's been called in
just trying to Governor Northam and what
he said is they sent 200 of State Police
and a unit of the National Guard they're
breaking windows and going in uh uh
obviously ransacking our offices and all
the rest of that that's nothing the
concern we have about uh personal safety
personal safety is it just transcends
everything but the fact is on any given
day they're breaking the law in many
different ways
and quite frankly much of it at the
instigation of the president of the
United States
and now if he could could at least uh
somebody yeah why don't you get the
president to tell them to leave the
capital Mr attorney general in your law
enforcement responsibility a public
statement they should all leave
cannot be just we're waiting for so and
so we need them there now whoever you
got
okay you also have troops this is Denny
Hoyer okay so we have a perfect day
Andrews Air Force Base all right other
military bases thank you we need active
duty National Guard how soon in the
future can you have the place evacuated
you know cleaned out
yeah
[Music]
and let me say you can logistically get
people there as you make the plan
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
we're trying to figure out how we can
get this job done today we talked to
Mitch about it earlier he's not in the
room right now but he was with us
earlier uh and said you want to expedite
this and hopefully they could confine it
to just one complaint Arizona and then
we could vote and and that would be you
know then just move forward with the
rest of the state the overriding wish is
to do it at the Capitol what we are
being told very directly is it's going
to take days for the capital to be okay
again we've gotten a very bad report
about the conditions of of the um house
floor with defecation and all that kind
of thing as well I don't think that
that's hard to clean up but I do think
it is more from a security standpoint of
making sure that everybody is out of the
building and how long will that take I
just got off with the vice president and
I got off with the vice president-elect
but what we left the conversation with
because he said he had the impression
for Mitch that Mitch wants to get
everybody back to do it there yes I said
well we're getting a Counterpoint that
is
time to clean up the poo poo that
they're making all over the literally
and figuratively in the capital and that
it may take days to get back
he just informed me what you will hear
Through official channels Paul Irving
your search engine arms we'll inform you
that their best information is that they
believe
able to recently in roughly an hour good
news
thank you very much